what's the message you want viewers to
take away from after it's the message
about without giving away the end i
think i think that the yeah i mean i
think i think the number one message is
that that there is a passion and a
belief and a support for the pain from
depression to PSD to you know that
you're not alone and that you know we
we've gone down this journey with you
and you know their healing can happen
and obviously it's a slow long drawn-out
process but for sure this is something
we can all get over eventually right i
would i would actually second that you
know you're not alone and i know a lot
of movies like to tie everything up in a
nice pretty bow and everything's fine
everybody moves on its great and we're
all happy and healthy and we wanted to
just make sure that it stayed real to
the ending of there on the road back and
they all know it's a long road but
they're all on it and they're you know
they're in the buggy chugging along
knowing that there if you're willing and
a willing participant in healing it can
happen you just have to you have to be
there and stay present and willing to
work through it and have people
approached you after screenings and
thank to you yes it's been amazing
that's been a something I you know about
you but I did not expect that we're
getting the response and it's so nice
because we made it for people not that
critics aren't awesome and wonderful you
know it wasn't even in my head like oh
my gosh will they like it or what did
the critics gonna I needed to make it
for people in my it's actually for
myself a healing process but yeah and
from all different takes from my small
business like totally out we were like
oh wow right because of the economy at
the time and people were losing their
businesses and their homes and their
loan
and you know I wrote that because that
was what was going on but to hear my son
had to do this and I feel the connective
aspect to it too for people to share I
mean it's such a humbling thing you know
while I didn't lose in this event that
you're discussing my sister did go in a
car accident my mom was like this for a
couple weeks like everything was just
nope everything's fine right I'll find
that that didn't happen everything's
we're good a layer of denial yeah yeah
cuz that's ultimately what it's about
how real how real the situation is
because it's one of those things where I
don't know if people really are in tune
or want to address how dark depression
and PSD can be and to hear people come
to us and say my grandmother she
completely separated or my father or my
and that's that's one of those things
that you didn't expect to connect you
know we were just kind of telling the
story for our own process and it
developed into movie from there and then
you know actually we put in it out so
you don't expect people to grab you in
the lobby and just talk to you talk to
you and talk to you about so much of
their own personal be so we'll helping
them to heal that they're not alone so
that's been a gift absolutely it's been
at your gift
you